[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm rhett and i'm linked this week at
the round table of dim lighting
we're talking about life post
vaccination
we're talking about when i'm fully
vaccinated i'm gonna fill in that big
old blank
and we're both half back
next as of this recording and soon to be
fully vaxxed and so we're going to talk
about
the excitement and the anticipation and
then the re-entry
into more of normal life or
just how we've anticipated that in our
brains
versus the reality of starting to carry
that out
and also talking about a phenomenon
called um
reentry anxiety so i'm talking about
space travel
no i'm talking about or sorting the mail
no no not talking about that but yes i
think you know there's
there's there's kind of a dark side to
getting on
with our lives uh having been vaccinated
and of course that's not to say you know
we're recording this
and then releasing it a few weeks later
so just in full disclosure
we're always a little bit ahead of the
game there's some things that you know
we're not as current as possible and
things change and update
so quickly i just want to put that out
there yeah
um and you know what because we're
talking about vaccines
um there is a lot of vaccine
hesitant hesitancy out there right so
um you know me i can't just
i can't just move along i can't just get
my vaccine and not say anything about it
um so here's what i wanted to do before
we get into the rest of the the episode
yeah i wanted to make my
vaccine pitch my
pitch for why i think you should get the
vaccine i got it and i think that you
should get it if you're not in a risk
group and if you qualify there's a lot
of information
floating around um yeah and it sways
people
most people like me you know you just
want to make a decision and get on
with your life and you know i don't go
on facebook i don't do
i i i find myself avoiding engaging
in a lot of the information and the deep
dives because
it stresses me out and i just want to
get on with it and move past this and
that's not necessarily a healthy thing
but i know that there's a lot of people
like me out there
that are well they haven't gotten
vaccinated they don't know if they are
but just looking at the information and
all the conflicting opinions is very
intimidating
overwhelming anxiety inducing and you
just want to curl up in a ball
and and avoid it we live in a very
interesting time where it is
legitimately very difficult
to move forward with decisions like this
without at least some
sort of hesitancy because of the way the
information
and misinformation spreads right and
because there's so much attachment to
what these decisions mean
about who you are who you're affiliated
with what what your core beliefs
are everything has been politicized it's
very
yeah it's loaded this all these
decisions
and and perspectives are so loaded well
here's what i'm going to try to do i'm
going to try to put this
in again i'm not a scientist i'm not a
doctor
you already knew that um i'm a guy
who eats weird things on the internet
and has a podcast with his best friend
hi link hey but i am a concerned citizen
and um i've been thinking about this in
a way that i
i hope can cut through a lot of
uh a lot of the numbers and the
the arguments and a lot of things that
can get kind of confusing and misleading
and just kind of talk to you as a friend
now first of all
if you think that the medical
establishment is an extension of the
deep state
and the vaccine campaign is a scheme to
inject microchips into people to control
them
this pitch is not for you okay you can
fast forward or you're probably not
listening already
uh but if you are listening i do have
something for you at the end so please
stick around
this is my pitch for those of you who
are on the fence
you have reservations about the vaccine
you've heard about the side effects what
about those blood clots weren't these
vaccines developed really quickly how do
you know
that they're safe long term and by the
way covet isn't that dangerous
why would i get a vaccine with unknown
side effects when i'd probably be fine
if i got covet if you thought anything
like that
this is for you okay so let's start with
the
the ultimate purpose of the vaccine the
vaccine is not
primarily about protecting you
individually from the virus
vaccines are our best available tool for
eliminating disease across a population
in this case all of humanity
that's this is how we end a disease so
framing
the decision around your own personal
risk is kind of missing the point
this isn't about you as much as it's
about us
it's not a me thing it's a we thing
now speaking of the we thing if we don't
reach
herd immunity there's a real risk of
cova continuing to evolve and form
variants and we're going to be dealing
with this for a very long time
the more people who get the vaccine the
more likely we beat it
and even if we don't reach herd immunity
which given the vaccine hesitancy
and the limit to roll out around the
world
there's a very real possibility we will
not reach herd immunity as we would like
to
but even so more vaccines mean
less of a problem with covid for
everybody down the line
so it's not like a lost cause by any
means
now you may have heard that the vaccines
don't stop infection or transmission but
they only lessen the symptoms
you might be asking why do i have to
wear a mask
after i get vaccinated well scientists
are actually
very hesitant to make claims until they
have good data it's kind of their thing
but they're getting a lot of data very
quickly
and the latest data indicates that these
new vaccines not only prevent severe
covet
and hospitalization almost completely
but they also very likely prevent
infection as well as transmission
therefore
the hesitancy to move beyond masks and
social distancing
has been because we want to make sure
that that is the case
okay that that's a big part for that a
big part of that
but what about the risks this seems to
be the thing that most people talk about
what about the risks
specifically the thing that i hear a lot
is if the mortality rate of covet is so
low
is it worth taking the risk of getting
the vaccine
well the mortality rate of covet isn't
that low i mean there are a lot of
factors and data still coming in but
covet is likely at least 10 times more
deadly than the flu
but i'll give it to you even if you get
it especially if you're not in a risk
group
you very likely will not die from covet
now for me a healthy dude
not that young 43 but i'm not in a risk
group
i don't have risk factors but it's the
long-term complications from cova that
are the most concerning to me personally
long-term symptoms affect people of all
ages and have occurred in people with
mild
moderate and severe cova 19 these can
include lung damage heart damage lasting
fatigue joint pain neurological
disorders loss of loss of taste and
smell sleep disorders
and these are showing up in significant
numbers
okay but okay i i get that
but what about the risks of the vaccines
well let's start with the blood clots
from the j and j vaccine the johnson
johnson vaccine because that's what
at least right now as we're recording
this that's what everybody's talking
about
six people out of about seven million
who were vaccinated develop blood clots
uh and as of today as of recording this
one of those people have
has died that's horrible that's
upsetting
um but just to put that into perspective
it's about
one in a million chance of getting a
blood clot and a one in a million
one in seven million chance of dying
from a blood clot from the j j vaccine
to put that into perspective you're much
more likely to die in a car accident on
the way to get the vaccine than you are
to get a blood clot from the vaccine
much less like much less die from the
vaccine
but keep in mind they still paused the j
j vaccine
in many places because of this risk
because
the scientists are actually very
concerned with safety so much so
when there's this statistical blip on
the radar
they stop to evaluate they're not trying
to take advantage of you they're not
trying to use you as guinea pigs
they're actually showing that safety is
their number one priority okay but
that's j j
that's only like a small percentage of
the vaccines
what about mrna the moderna which is
what i got in the pfizer which is what
you got
this stuff's unproven right i mean we
are just a bunch of guinea pigs
being experimented on well
we have a lot of good reasons to believe
that mrna vaccines are safe
likely safer than traditional vaccines
for a number of reasons so they
underwent some of the most rigorous
safety testing ever
fast quick yes but rigorous
nonetheless but what about the long-term
risks
well these vaccines are actually not
that new
trials were conducted for mrna vaccines
in 2009 for prostate cancer
2013 for rabies and mrna vaccines were
already in clinical trials for hiv
cancer in zika
patients before the development of the
cova vaccines and nothing found in those
trials led to hesitancy
to move forward with covet 19 vaccines
this isn't something that was just
pulled out of the back pocket of
scientists
and doctors in response to this uh
pandemic it was something they had been
working on for quite some time
and the mechanism of mrna vaccines
is a new approach to vaccines but it's
actually
really straightforward and there are
lots of advantages including
safety now there's a lot of
misinformation about this but messenger
rna doesn't get anywhere near the
nucleus of the cell
that contains human dna and it
disintegrates quickly after the message
that it is communicating is read it does
not alter your dna because it cannot
alter your dna
uh now you may have read on the internet
about scary things like antibody
dependent enhancement
the idea that getting these vaccines is
going to cause you to actually have a
higher chance of dying
down the line from getting covid19
especially a variant
or that there are ingredients in the
vaccine that might cause cancer
all of this was taken into account when
developing the vaccine
and there is no reason to believe that
these are risks from the vaccines just
plain and simple
there's a lot of good literature on all
of this and how these things were
studied in depth
throughout the development including the
antibody dependent enhancement which is
something i see a lot of people talk
about
now does that mean that nobody will have
adverse short-term or long-term
complications from the vaccine
of course not people are going to have
adverse reactions to this vaccine
and with so many people being vaccinated
we're going to see
significant you know statistically small
but significant because
anything that happens to a person is
significant and worrying
in some people right uh the most common
adverse reaction is going to be an
allergic reaction that's that's kind of
what we've seen so far but we have every
reason to believe
that the long-term complications from
covit itself pose a
much higher risk so here's the bottom
line
the only way to justify vaccine
hesitancy as it relates to
vaccine risk compared to the risk of
covet itself
is to drastically overestimate the risk
of the vaccines
while drastically underestimating the
risk of covet itself
do you see what i'm saying there people
who have hesitancy about the vaccine
tend to also diminish what the real
risks of kovid
are it's kind of like saying i'm not
gonna go on that flight to california to
free solo climb the face of el capitan
because
flying is dangerous or
maybe a better example lots of people
who are scared of flying have absolutely
no problem driving to the airport
even though they're way more likely to
die in the car on the way to the
airport than in the plane on the way to
their destination
this is an irrational fear based on risk
perception
not actual risk and the same thing is
happening with a lot of people who are
getting the vaccine
who are not getting the vaccine same
thing is happening with a lot of people
who are not getting the vaccine
so in summary step one properly framing
the issue is key
assessing whether or not you should get
the vaccine should be framed first
as a community issue not as a personal
one
the collective risk to everyone is much
higher when you don't get the vaccine
in step two you gotta properly frame
the risk we have good reason to believe
that your personal risk from getting the
vaccine is significantly less than your
risk from acquiring covid
and experiencing adverse effects now
this is still
taking into account the fact that you
voluntarily get the vaccine
but you won't necessarily get covet you
see what i'm saying people are like well
i don't choose to get covet but i'm
choosing to get the vaccine doesn't that
inherently
increase the risk of the vaccine no the
kovid risk is still
greater just being a person who lives in
the world
so even if you're thinking about this as
an individual it still makes sense for
you
and your personal safety to get the
vaccine
so please for all of us get the vaccine
now if you're a conspiracy theorist
thank you for sticking around that's why
i've just been
hanging out here um you may be wondering
why i took this time in our com
some sometimes comedy podcast usually
comedy podcast
uh to put together this message i'm
gonna come clean
i'm a part of the deep state i'm being
personally
paid by dr fauci who is a friend of mine
who has my venmo account
to communicate this message on behalf of
the deep state
to the end of being able to control as
many people as we possibly can
in the long-term future dr fauci and i
regularly attend sorry link i'm letting
you know this for the first time as well
i'm yeah i'm regularly attending kind of
floored hollywood parties together at
least we did before
before kova we we look forward to
going back to those parties where mainly
the thing that we do i mean there's
cocktails
and there's mingling but we kind of do
that for like 90 minutes and then we all
go to the basement
and that's when we do the real good
stuff which is drink the blood of
children
now you may be wondering how do i have
such
good skin at the age of 43 it's not
some sort of like face washing and
you know uh exfoliation routine it's
regularly drinking the blood of children
how is that it's it's got a metallic
taste okay
but we put it through a brita oh and you
still get the stuff that you need the
uh adrenochrome gotcha
if you want to stay young if you want to
be in control
if you want to be on the side of the
people who are going to win in the
future
join me and dr falchi drink the blood of
children
you heard it here
and yet i haven't been invited okay i
didn't think you were ready yet
okay there it is the laptop's going away
uh you know i appreciate you organizing
those thoughts
and putting that out into the world um
because it's it's easy to be overwhelmed
by information
i think a lot of it has to do with
people are making decisions based on who
did who do they trust
and why and what are
what do you really want personally like
what are your
what are your motives and your values
and how do those things all add up
you know so there's a lot of people who
are just it's just it really comes down
for a lot of people
and i think this is my experience a lot
of times just who are you following who
are you trusting
yeah and why r really
why well we we could do
uh uh we could do all not just a podcast
but a whole show
on how you choose uh
where you get your information from and
what the point of that is and
how how if you can trust medic i mean
first of all some of the numbers that i
threw out and the statistics and the
data
i know there's a lot of people who are
just like well you just believe all
the propaganda data you don't believe
the real data which i can find on the
internet
again there's not that's such a
pervasive problem in our society right
now there's nothing i'm going to be able
to say
uh that's going to sway you on that the
only thing i can ask
uh is just continue to be open-minded
and
you know self-critical um
you know i'm not i'm not going to try to
change your mind on that i'm just going
to joke about
dr fauci but i'm not joking though it's
true i drink the blood of children
i want to make that clear all right so
let's shift gears a little bit
into what now
we we've made our decisions we're about
to you know in a couple of days i'm
gonna get that second
dose in my arm and then i got two weeks
later
and then i'm totally free and this is
what i've been looking forward to
since the very beginning of lockdown and
then you
you know so i think
there is an evolving set of guidelines
associated with what you can and can't
and should and shouldn't do
once you're fully vaccinated so
disclaimer at this point
again this is three weeks old even the
moment it comes out because of
when we're having to record this
conversation so
we do defer and direct you to the
latest and greatest guidelines um
that we are not giving here and what to
do and not do
when you are fully vaccinated okay
having said that i think we can safely
assume
uh or for the purposes of this
conversation so we don't have to keep
coming back to that point
i think that the way that i'm thinking
about this question is
uh i'm just kind of saying if things
were to
suddenly get back to normal and i was
able to do all the things that i did
before
how do i perceive those things and and
what am i thinking about those things
whether that be
going to a movie or a concert or
whatever i don't know exactly when those
things are going to happen
but i'm just saying for the purposes of
this conversation
i'm thinking about like the next year
and the freedoms that might come back
yeah
and so let's start in that positive
aspirational place
and then you know i i'm sure we'll talk
about the
the anxiety flip side of that and kind
of dealing with that
even some of that i've personally
had a taste of already and it surprised
me
but let's let's just start at the i mean
what are the first
things just like throw out
words restaurants okay for me
that's a big one for me movies i haven't
been to a movie
movies uh i'm on board with movies let's
come back to all these concerts uh yeah
you know in a way that i've never felt
about concerts before i'm like
now's the time i'm actually i'm gonna be
that concert
guy extended family visits
going back home to north carolina
parties parties
okay now you're really getting into it
parties
with people that you know and parties
with people that you don't know
wow there's two kinds of parties okay so
i'm talking get togethers and then i'm
talking like
parties i'm talking about the me and
fauci in the basement
drinking the blood of children with a
stranger and not worried about anything
especially the children
i don't know how many times i'm going to
keep coming back to that because i know
it's offensive to people but
i just don't can't help it i'm really
tempted to go
just keep going i'm going harder in it
but i don't i i don't want to do it
people are just gonna i mean
by the way totally unrelated we've got
our friendship rings on today
look at that right hold up hold up your
hand there look at that
friendship ring day this is a previous
sponsor
we haven't we have not discussed this so
as an as a total aside
i feel like we need to get this out of
the way okay
we are wearing the exact same ring it
was a sponsor manly bands we might as
well say it again
right and one of the the stipulate not
stipulations but one of the
opportunities was you get to get a ring
i'm not going to promote something
unless i can experience it and know that
i want to promote it
but you so yeah you requested well just
the silicone
uh ring because they have like the like
basically like a rubber ring
that you can wear when you're doing like
activities and stuff a lot of people
wear them full time so you don't have to
worry about like your we've got we know
some people who've
got their fingers taken off because of
wedding rings because the ring got hung
on something uh
but you're like i wear there's a lot of
sentimental value with the ring that you
have because it was your grandfather's
ring so you're not gonna take that off
no i'm not gonna replace my wedding
so you asked for the silicone ring and i
was like well i just bought my wedding
ring for like 200 bucks before we got
married
uh i'll keep it around but i would i've
always wanted to have a wooden
ring because you know me and wood that's
not how i remember it at all right
you have a tendency to you have a
revisionist brain you have a super
revisionist brain just because we
disagree about something doesn't mean
that you're the one that's right
so let's be clear on that and we do have
a witness
are you going to tell me you're going to
tell me how to tell me that you chose
that ring
i'm a no i'm going to tell i'm going to
say okay we were given
they these are these are pricey rings
they're gonna send
one as a sample but they're not gonna
send two
that's what we were told true that so
then it was like oh well who gets the
ring
but that was when you said you didn't
want to change your wedding ring because
it has sentimental value
that didn't mean i didn't want a ring oh
i didn't know that
exactly because then you just said what
ring you wanted but i was like i'm happy
you know what i'm and then i'm like you
know what
if i really wanted a ring this would be
the point where i would say i
i'd like to try out a nice ring but i
elected not to
and then you were like oh they have wood
rings so then you
you chose this ring that we both are
wearing okay that's
that's the part i was like i was like
you know what i'm interested
i was like do they have one of those
rings that won't rip your finger off
a rubber ring i'll take one of those
because they're they're cheap and it
will try it
now by the way at this point having
gotten a sample that we did not pay for
i would gladly pay
for another one but i did not pay for
this one to match you what happened was
the ring that you ordered came and it
was too small
i don't know you screwed up the sizing
yeah i did
your fault not the sponsors yeah yeah
because
instead of sizing we told them what we
thought my size was and then i'm like
i bet it will fit my finger so the ring
that was too small for you
fit perfectly on my finger and then i
had a right hand and you didn't have one
right but then you ordered another one
because you really wanted it
even though now we got i did i was like
i got him
i know he's not gonna love this we have
friendship rings now uh so you're going
to keep wearing that yeah and i'm going
to call it our friendship ring
and while we're talking about i know you
i know that makes you what we're talking
about it's really uncomfortable i've
been wearing
the the aura ring you know this is
basically you know a fitness
ring biometric it measures biometrics
that's
it's not it is a fashion statement but
that wasn't my primary reason for
wearing it oh i ordered one of those too
well so we'll have double frames
but we both have new oil rings coming
and so
the question is yeah we're going we're
going to have two rings that are the
same
that's we should have gotten i think
that's kind of cool we should have
gotten different because there's
multiple options for order rings we
should have gotten maybe they'll send us
two different kinds and we're looking at
that okay sorry for the aside
but yeah i i enjoy having a friendship
ring with you
i'm sorry that i don't use you you do
have a revisionist
you have a revisionist mind but i
thought that you what you were saying
was you were gonna say is that you chose
this ring and i was like hold on a
second
no you didn't you knew i wasn't gonna
replace my wedding ring so you assumed i
didn't want a ring
and i have nine other fingers that's all
i'm saying
but i didn't know you were gonna start
doing the multiple rings on hands thing
because i
kind of just started doing that oh see
that's yours but
and i'm i'm stating and i'm saying you
know what multiple rings can't be your
thing
okay and i agree with that just like
glasses can't be your thing and beards
can't be yours
we are going to morph into one person i
mean i i don't listen i don't have an
appointment yet but i just want to go
and give you a fair warning that glasses
the last time i went to the eye doctor
over two years ago i was told that i
needed glasses
and you haven't gotten them because i'm
the guy with glasses but it started
i'm you're starting to send me over the
precipice because i've noticed that how
big you want things that we need to read
blown up and i'm like right
that's that's kind of getting to be too
much yeah i mean
the dude really can't see if they're
having trouble i'm having trouble seeing
it
uh okay so back to post pandemic
let's go back through these things the
first thing that came to my mind
was movies and then right when i'm on
the precipice of like
scheduling and i'm telling the kids i'm
like i don't even care what movie it is
right like i'll see that king kong
versus godzilla if i have to
right even though i have no interest
whatsoever in seeing it i just want to
be
in a movie theater and you know someone
told me when i
when i got to this point in the
conversation with him they said you know
you can rent out a whole theater now
because
uh i mean you got to pick a a slower
time
and just have all your friends show up
i'm like no no no i want to be where
they were strangers i want to do the old
thing i don't want to do this
rent out the theater thing and i don't
care what movie it is
and i know exactly where i'm going to go
my favorite theater
arclight cinemas the only theater at the
highest standard where they charge the
same amount no matter if you're a kid
or whatever so it it deters there's so
many reasons besides just
like not incentivizing bringing more
kids
in a disproportionate amount and for
those of you who are not from los
angeles and haven't been to los angeles
haven't been to
an arc light cinema just just a quick
little summary of
why they're the best okay it's more it's
it is more expensive
that they control every aspect of the
environment are you going to control the
conversation
well it's kind of my thing you know it's
my favorite theater well it's also my
favorite theater can i have a favorite
theater too
no you can't have the same favorite
theater it's everyone's favorite theater
los angeles they bring someone out
before
the show you know how sometimes like
you're at a movie theater
and and like it's not loud enough or
it's too loud or it's not in focus
and then you're like am i gonna have to
be the person to get up
and miss part of this movie and go tell
the guy who's serving popcorn
that they need to tell the guy who's
running the thing in the thing
that this is not working no that doesn't
happen at arc like they bring a person
out who greets you everyone and says
hey my name's daryl welcome to this
showing of king kong vs godzilla
it's a great film i enjoyed it this is
how long it lasts this is how long the
previews are going to be
and i'm going to be standing over here
to the side to make sure that the
picture and the sound quality are
perfect
before we move on yes they do it so you
don't have to talk to the
doofus who's serving popcorn not
everybody who searches popcorn as to do
this it's just in my experience
i've had to go talk to a doofus before
about this and that's why i'm frustrated
and you know that doesn't happen at the
arclight and it literally
is the first thing i've been looking
forward to doing and if you take your
phone out and text
at the arc light you will be there's a
laser that comes from behind the screen
and will
it'll obliterate you yes you will be
murdered
you're just yeah you're you're taken out
right because
that that inhibits everyone else's
experience
okay if you care about film or should i
say cinema
but they bring care about this they
bring in a clone of the person so if no
one ever knows if you're there with
loved ones
yeah and you're really enthralled in the
movie and um
you know somebody pulls out the phone
yes they're obliterated but they're
immediately replaced with a clone and
their phone is gone though
that's all these reasons make it the
number one thing i've been looking
forward to
and they just went under yeah all they
all discover
they waited they waited until the end of
the pandemic like literally right now
to announce oh you know what
can't do it anymore guys can't hang on
any longer we're gone
like weeks before everyone can start fl
i don't understand the timing i'm so
frustrated not just
i gotta find another theater that i'm
willing to watch movies in
not just arclight but because pacific
theaters bought arclight
pacific theaters which is i think is the
theater that's at
uh the americana that's not opening
either
crap oh well i think and other companies
will have to come in and and still make
it because they're still gonna what are
they gonna turn it into like
like a jump gym like one of those
trampoline places so i gotta still
make movies there i literally don't i
now have to find a new movie
experience because i've heard there's
still reason for hope
that there might be like jesse said it
had something to do with like this is
like a thing that happens
i think that there are also a lot of
people in los angeles who are making a
huge stink of this already because
maybe this is a film town we all stay
through the credits at the end of the
movie it's
i mean it's a super film snob town
because this is where so many
movies are okay maybe there's so i think
that we may come together as a community
and say we don't
just want to watch movies at our houses
we don't want to just watch movies
um at theaters where they don't have it
in focus
or it's not loud enough yeah we want to
watch movies at the arclight okay
i'll hold out a little hope it's kind of
like that thing where a company goes
bankrupt and then like a few months
later they're still around
right like what what so yeah some sort
of like tax
like trump employee yeah what happened
yeah
um so that that was literally my number
one if you were to put your number one
is it it's not restaurants no it's not
number one uh
it's not number one because i really
like my new television
you know i finally did the the finally
did the 4k
oled yeah television so what is your
number one
um eating i mean restaurants
and there's just something about eating
at a restaurant versus getting take out
from arrest
oh yeah i mean i've really forgotten i
think i'm gonna go to a restaurant and
be like
oh yeah this should have been my number
one
like the food tastes so much better like
we we
we supported our favorite restaurants
locally
and they'd send you their like signature
dishes
deconstructed yeah so that everything
doesn't over meld together
you lose you lose the presentation of
the food
you lose and many times many times you
lose the freshness of the food because
it's because it's coming to you
in a bag you also lose a big part of it
for me it's just the ambiance i mean i
for me eating is about all the senses
being stimulated
right and i i love eating at restaurants
i'd love the entire experience and yes i
understand that
there are restaurants that are open for
outdoor dining um
and that they're socially distance
dining and we haven't been doing that
right
so because um we've we've been following
heightened protocols associated with
production
so that our limited crew we can all
protect each other
and continue you know making our shows
our standards are higher
than just the general california
standards which are already higher than
the general
sort of national standards so we're
admittedly behind yeah but it's like
but even in my own brain i've locked off
the restaurant zone because it hurt too
much
after a few months at the beginning of
the pandemic to dwell on it
so now i'm finding it difficult to
reopen those compartments
but i think when i go to a restaurant
the other part i miss is that
yes you still got the whole phone
situation
in your pocket but but the
how it sets the stage for connection you
stare across the table
at somebody me and christy on a date
it's
a date is much different out than trying
to recreate it in your own home
matter of fact we just got to a point
where we thought we were going to do the
date thing and then it just didn't
happen
yeah we did it we held on for a little
bit just didn't have we did a thing for
a while where we would um
just like i would turn the lights down
put on some music
uh and we would eat at our little sort
of breakfast nook
and then we would make the kids eat in a
different room or like eat in the dining
room
right i don't know it worked for a while
but
it's just so hard to maintain the
separation and the discipline
yeah and then you're still doing the
dishes and the preparation
yeah even even if you order out yeah you
know it's like just being
being waited on in a restaurant is so
awesome
yeah i mean i love the experience and
it's like i mean i mean it
i'm starting to get excited now because
it's like i mean i think i'm gonna be at
a restaurant
and i'm gonna be like wow i feel like a
king like there'll be just
this renewed appreciation for the whole
thing look someone's coming up and just
anything i want well and i can just tell
this stranger
and they'll go away and they'll come
back with it and that's
what i mean one of the many reasons that
the cost of living in los angeles is so
high
you know compared to
north carolina for instance um
is the event like we're so close to so
many things
including so many great places to eat
like there's just so
many you can never eat at the same place
twice
and keep having these completely
dynamic excellent dining experiences
maybe one of your your favorite things
in l.a yeah as well it's i mean it's one
of the things i'm like
when i think about how much money i pay
to live here
i'm like you can't you kind of have to
start reminding yourself of the
the advantages because especially one of
the reasons there's been this mass
exodus
of people from from los angeles during
the pandemic is because they're like
if all i'm doing is hanging out at home
why am i going to be in this
tiny little expensive place
where i can go to a less expensive
larger place and have the same
experience and have the same experience
right
i totally get it i under we're not
moving because we have a
we've built our lives here and we built
our business here but it's like i'm
ready to experience the city
that i'm paying so much for well i mean
i came
so close to buying a van that you know
i wouldn't live out of it but i would
travel and semi live out of it on little
trips
you know and i that's taking a back
burner now it's like
i can rent somebody else's van whenever
i want to do that but i'm
yeah so that's the update on that
aspiration it was i had the tunnel
vision
of the pandemic goggles you know
and i'm gonna i'm gonna rent a van again
i'm gonna
trust me i'm gonna do it but um i'm not
i don't i'm pretty sure i'm not gonna
buy one
this the other aspect of this is parties
now before we get a part let's let's go
with the friends
because i think that's well that's what
i think that's what i'm saying there's
two aspects of this
and so i'm saying that the first part
which i've experienced a little bit of
is getting together at people's homes
right
now very recently uh
so we so uh we got together with another
well okay so there's a couple that was
fully vaccinated
jesse and i uh are you know jesse's
fully vaccinated now i'm
vaccinated and one you know once you're
a few weeks out from the initial dose of
these moderner pfizer
you're you're very well protected
especially if you're around other people
who are vaccinated right
and so we made so there's there's we see
each other
and we see this one other family but
there was a friend who we hadn't seen in
over a year who was at this family's
house
and texted us and said hey
i'm over here i'm fully fully vaccinated
they're totally cool if you guys come
over and it was a friday night
and uh it was probably it was like sit
it was like 7 30 or eight it was like
eight i i
already here's the thing i already i had
my plan
and my plan was we were gonna watch a
movie and
i don't even know what it was but i had
it picked out and then we got the text
and i was like
ah i kind of had this plan but i haven't
seen this person in a year
yes let's go and we go over there
and i mean again there's like
hugs first thing was
we're hugging this is uh this is a
little bit unusual
right just i haven't hugged a lot of
people yeah in
in in a long time now you're not a
hugger so when that happened
um what was your experience because
there are people who are huggers
and they're like that might be the top
of their list to have like physical
connection
with i'm
uh i'm not a hug instigator but i'm not
an auntie i'm not you're not i'm not an
anti-hug
yeah but you're not i'm a hug i'm a good
hug receiver
right and like i'm a good hug
reciprocator
you're kind of neutral you could i think
you could take it or leave it
i think i could too no no judgment here
how was it
so given that you could take or leave a
hug in normal life
uh what was it therapeutic was there a
release
i don't or was it the same i'm not i
don't want to be dramatic
so don't be dramatic i'm just saying be
honest yeah i'm saying that
i'm going to be honest and say that it
was really good
but it wasn't like man
that feels good that feels different
that's that's like a
giant step forward it didn't it did not
feel that way for me
it just felt in fact as we then sat down
and began to have a conversation
around the kitchen table it began
very quickly to feel like old times
again
and i actually consciously sort of
stepped out of the conversation and went
into my own head and thought to myself
like
this is interesting because
i feel like i'm
totally here again like i feel like the
past
year is just a memory
now i know again it's going to be a slow
process of getting back to normal
and i know this is not i say this you
know
being sensitive to the fact that this is
not the case for a lot of people
but it just kind of hit me i was like
hmm
i'm immediately back in the same mind
space
and social space and social experience
that i was before all this happened
like having this conversation but
i could tell that not everyone at that
table
felt the same way and you should also
say
who from my family was or wasn't at that
table so
we began to talk about you because you
and christy had also received the text
from this person to come over yep
and um there was a conversation
and the conversation was they were like
you think lincoln christie you're coming
i was like well this is between you and
jesse are you
already at the already i was like well
you know lincoln christie they the neo
plan may already be in effect and this
may be
difficult for them to dislodge from this
and then we had a conversation
and you pretty much knew what that plan
was well and i'll just say it's funny
because
okay so it was it was the mccarg's house
uh
and because mike said
well here's the spectrum on this end of
the spectrum
in terms of i can't remember the term
that he used but it was basically like
social flexibility or something like
that he was like you have the niels
and the mccarks yep um together on one
end and at the opposite end
very socially inflexible you have the
mclaughlins
and i was like well let me butt in and
say
that is true the mclaughlin's and the
person who was the
the guest there i was like that's true
of my wife
but i'm kind of in the middle i i kind
of straddle the fence on this one
because i will admit that it was not
easy for me to just drop what i wanted
to do and watch a movie and come over
it like i can't i tend to kind of get
into a plan and as soon as we finish
that conversation
knock knock knock your wife and daughter
show up but noticeably you're not there
yeah so
just to rewind a little bit yeah
we're sitting down like we've it's
it's eight o'clock-ish so all the kneels
without prompting now we all gather on
in the tv room on the couch
and we put on survivor every every
single night
on friday night yeah even friday night
like
i i gave up a long time ago on trying to
like say
yeah but on the weekends we're not doing
survivor that's a weeknight thing on the
weekends we're gonna like
do our own things or we're gonna watch
movies or it's gonna
it's gonna feel like a normal weekend
not just like another night
like every single night we watch
survivor friday night i mean even with
your kids
even me i was like this is too much guys
and i lost
i lost the argument and then i was okay
with that okay and then months later
i'm really okay with it and then this
this one night it's like any other night
for the past
year we look forward to this we relish
in it
if you know if anything breaks that up
just within the home somebody gets mad
you know it's like if somebody's not as
into one division
as the rest of the family introducing
like
putting one division above survivor or
has been a problem yeah like how do you
watch other things or how do you watch
movies we double up
we don't watch movies we watch what we
watch
movies we watch if it's whatever is on
disney plus that we're all
the new series that we're all going to
watch we watch that on friday and then
we watch survivor afterwards
it's it's it's it's ridiculous i know it
is
we're so extreme what are you going to
do like at this pace you're definitely
going to run out
we are halfway through the season 39
finale how many seasons are there 40.
so you're getting closer running out and
last night we we paused it
at a strategic halfway point of the
finale because it was getting to be it's
a school night it's getting to be
bedtime
and i'm like guys i don't think we
should go
like tomorrow night we're going to watch
the rest of the finale and then the next
night
i know you're going to want to just
start with season 40. that's the last
one
and we've heard that it's like the best
season
i i don't want to go to it i want i want
to wait
ah the complaining starts like no dad
you're being cr
it's like there are some episodes
seasons that we skipped
i think we should delay the
gratification of season 40
go back and watch somebody we're so into
it now let's watch some of the seasons
that people said
sucked that you become dependent we are
dependent on survivor every single night
to survive
so i'm like listen we're gonna blow
through season 40
in two weeks that's that's the
pace we've been on yeah we kept
increasing i mean it is this like
dependent compulsion
leading to addiction kind of uh
uh trajectory you're gonna have to
figure out some sort
i'm trying to point that out to him last
night i'm like listen guys
we need to delay season 40 so that we
can build it up more and look forward to
it even if we skip
three nights i want to keep that season
40 dangling out there until it's closer
to season 41 coming out
and then i'm also talking about when
lily goes off to college i'm like
you know what are we going to do with
survivors she's like we'll just we'll
just watch it and talk about it i was
like no no no we want to save survivor
for holidays when we're all back
together
and then we're going to watch those
seasons this is how small my world has
become
two weeks ago we talked about the
wanting to look into communes it was
very tongue-in-cheek but it was rooted
in this feeling that i have of
i really like the control and this and
the perceived
different kind of safety that has
nothing to do with covet or pandemics
of just smallness of this is this is my
world now
and this i know what to expect and
it's it is it is fostering
some things that aren't healthy and that
are this is what i discovered
and this was this was a moment it was a
test
we were sitting down and then
christy looks up she's like
he we're invited over to the macarx to
see so and so
and he he's over there now he's fully
vaccinated
and she locks eyes with me and
i bet if you were to ask her what she
saw in my eyes i think it would be fear
and it had nothing to do with the friend
or how much
i i love and miss him it was
and it wasn't just about a threat to the
routine but it was
things are changing now we had already
planned
to get together this was a friday night
we had already planned to get together
on sunday night at my house and i was
i was getting mentally prepared for that
and then this was dropped in my life and
i'm like well you know it's
i was just i was getting ready for
sunday
and now this thing right now right now
and um
there were some mitigating circumstances
in our in our house
i had actually just gotten the vaccine
the day before
and uh experienced a headache
and then then i thought i i felt totally
good
that day the second day which is the day
in question
and i went for a bike ride when i got
back the headache came back i
i did too much too soon on day two
shouldn't have done that
i actually didn't feel good um and
you know there were other members of the
family you can figure it out by matter
of elimination that
just that were reticent for their own
reasons
so that led to i'm gonna stay at home
with them and we can
we can blame it on the kids but i have
these things going inside of me and i
don't know what's happening
in my brain and with my emotions but i
just
i don't i'm not willing or ready to do
this
i'm not i'm not motivated enough to
overcome these feelings tonight
i'm i'm i'm working forward to being
ready by sunday
and then i i ended up we watched
survivor without christy
and lily because it really gave us
permission to and i felt dirty and
horrible and i said
it didn't feel right and i don't want to
ever do that again and then i went to
bed and my head was
killing me and i was so i was glad i
wasn't there i wouldn't have
i wouldn't have been a positive
contributor to
that reunion even though i hate that i
didn't get to see
our friend and i you know i don't want
him to think that it had anything to do
with him specifically
but it really brought to light things
that i was just not aware of
at that moment and then you know so
we're getting
we can get back to the positives but we
might as well go through this anxiety
because that's what i
i never thought i never had
what i would call social anxiety i don't
think
it's so hard to remember so you think
that that's what it is for you
well like okay maybe that's one way to
describe it but what if you were invited
to
like let let's not just say it's a it's
a get together with people that you
know and you've seen a bunch and then
one additional person but like
an actual social thing like a like a
party like i do
like even when we have like when you do
you did your monthly game night and you
had extent
like more friends show up for that
including us back in the day pre-covered
pre-covert there were
some time i do notice that there's a
little heightened level of anxiety
that i experience associated with even
with that but i
some of it's just excitement that can
feel like anxiety
so i didn't really know what was going
on but i was
i will say that there are plenty of
times that i'm not
totally at ease even with
like my second-tier friends that like i
totally trust and enjoy and love
so there was an inkling of that that i
recall from pre-covet
but now on sunday night when we got
together i got to tell you the thing
that you saw when you looked around the
table and
you see you could see in people's eyes
they were experiencing something that
you weren't
um you felt totally normal and
maybe exhilarated to be back together
even on sunday night when we all got
together
i actually felt when we left i felt a
little discouragement
you know there's a lot of self-judgment
that i'd you know that
tends to come into play with me but
there's i'm a lot
more im i'm a lot more in my head right
now
because of this whole reentry thing you
were and i even realized i did notice
that you were quieter
than normal i felt weird you know it was
just like
because it's a combination of
getting reintroduced to something that i
feel like
should be just like flipping a switch
well but and it but it wasn't and it
wasn't anybody's fault and it wasn't
nobody did or said anything to make me
feel weird
it was just i and
another part of it might just be sheer
unmet expectations
you know you build something up and you
look forward to it then you
then you let go of it and then you
realize it's coming back
and now there's fear in the equation but
it
but you still have this hope that like
this is going to be so
dynamic this is going to be
i mean i never been to prison
but i would be interested to talk to
somebody who
has experienced re-entry from prison
it's a probably a little bit
more intense more intense but
there's i there's a there's a sliver of
parallel at least you know
i could tell i could tell that i
made note that multiple people
both on friday night and on sunday night
were not acting
like themselves um and
or what i remember of them in those
settings right and i didn't notice that
about you as like links being like
typically
uh he's he's very talkative sometimes we
have to
pull him back a little bit yeah but that
is not and i really thought i would have
been
especially with the prep i'd be like i
don't want to come on too strong
and but okay but what i ended up doing
was after dinner
we're all kind of like hanging out and
um
i needed to use the restroom so i went
upstairs to use it
and i and and i will do this at
most get togethers at my house
i will go upstairs and then i'll be like
i'm gonna just hang
here for a second but that was and i did
that
on a sunday night you did disappear for
a little bit uh but i
always do that and always did that it
wasn't longer than
i would believe like an involved dump
would take
i don't even think it was a dump i think
i just oh i know i'm just saying you had
to pee
the amount of time that yeah yeah was
underwater you gotta you gotta you gotta
keep in mind you don't wanna like draw
attention to how long you're in the back
right but
people start thinking things they start
assuming things but that's
that's my introversion that's my i got
okay
i i got time for people and i got energy
from people then i have to pull it back
but but i actually as it was happening i
because i'm also in my own head about
this a little bit i was like
is this am i having like uh uh
like uh my energy has been impacted by
this
this this pandemic and i've got low
capacity for people right now then i was
like no no no you're just an introvert
and you did this before the pandemic
so i just kind of went back downstairs
but in the midst of the conversation
like
all right we're having a conversation
for to me
i was also thinking and noticing it i
was like i kind of feel like i'm just
back where we left off but i can tell
that more than a few people are not at
that place because our conversation
feels different there are more gaps
there are more
there's more like awkward why do we keep
talking about dogs so much like that's
the thing i told christy i was like you
know i was disappointed that like
i kind of thought we would talk about
what we were experiencing kind of what
we're talking about now
and i was i was like i feel like i would
have had a better time if we could have
just talked about that
but maybe you talked about that some on
friday night without us and then
and i was like but we ended up talking
about
dogs like on four four different
times like we were over here eating and
then we moved over here and then we went
inside and it was just like
i was like we don't have as much to talk
about we keep going back to dogs
i don't know that's
you've always attached expectations to
what conversations will be
yep that was that's not a pandemic thing
that's a link thing
there's many times and this is sort of a
gripe between my wife and you this is
like one of the sources of conflict
between jessie and
you yeah is like jess you'll start
talking about something you'll be like
ah
can we let's not talk about that right
now
right no normally not not dogs
cause like i could have said i think
legitimately uh we you know we've talked
about dogs
three times tonight i'm curious
how are you guys doing because i feel
weird as [ __ ] right now
you know it's like yeah but i also
didn't have the energy and i didn't want
to
do that at that moment but uh you know i
i i do own the uh the conversation
police thing because
it is an outward manifestation of my
my inner critic and the control thing
that has to do with expectations
associated with connecting with people
uh whether that's like the dynamics
i think about it too much oh who's
included who's interesting can we you
know
are we you know it's too much too much
for people
um so on that piece of it so yeah it's
kind of like parsing
what what's true my former self what's
new in the mix now
what in in this being a process
you know i even you know i i did a
search
because i i know that there's people who
are dealing with this
more like and to a greater degree
there's people who
might have already been agoraphobic or
have some sort of social anxiety
already that wasn't something like me
that's like did i have that
is that where this is coming from um
nearly 50
of americans say they feel anxious about
resuming in-person interactions
post-pandemic according to a report from
the american psychological
association a phenomenon psychological
psychologists have dubbed re-entry
anxiety
hey kiko put a put an echo on that thank
you
reentry anxiety
yeah i've heard of that i've heard a lot
of people talking about it i found you
know i just want to go
through this and i don't want to get
bogged down in it but
scl health i think this is like colorado
hospital
it doesn't matter very practical advice
um to deal with if you're if you're
struggling with re-entry anxiety
uh just like a handful of things first
they say start small
if you haven't left the house in much
over the last year don't suddenly rip
off the band-aid and walk into the most
crowded marketplace you can find start
small
plan a hike with a few friends work your
way up from there
slowly confronting your sources of fear
with a little more exposure each time
exposure therapy
is is what is called by doctors this
next point
really resonated with me start soon
um if anything is making you anxious
you should confront the issue as soon as
possible the longer you wait the more
the anxiety foments and works itself
up so not only does social isolation
have short-term health implications it
can impact mental health long term
it doesn't mean you should throw a party
um
and you need to be subject to you know
the guidelines as you said up front but
a little socialization
goes a long way you got to say i'm i'm
engaging
in this process of reentry and i'm
i you know i have to take baby steps and
i need to start
soon or now another another thing was
um a piece of advice was looking at the
big picture
a good thing to do is to ask yourself
what truly makes me happy
and whether that's family the outdoors
returning back to life let the big
picture be a major motivator to overcome
the fears
um in comparison to them
in combating reasons to not start or
delay
you know i i was gearing up for sunday i
wasn't ready for friday
i listened to myself and you know
but if there wasn't a sunday plan
i'd i might would have felt differently
now about my decision to not go on
friday
and then two more things buddy up find
someone
you know and trust uh who's in a similar
phase
or has a similar experience and
understands you that you can buddy up
with and support each other
through the re-entry process talking
about it
i mean even this conversation is freeing
for me because it's like
hey you've heard what's inside of my
head i've kind of given you this
emotional brain dump
so to speak so it's i think
the next time we're like if it's next
weekend
that we're in a small group setting
you know there might be an opportunity
for you to say something to me
or me to say something to somebody else
who's open up to me that type of thing
you know i think it really helps
and then uh yeah they they know it in
the end for some people it's gonna be a
breeze
like the way you described it could
potentially
you know i could experience jealousy or
envy or or beat myself up because
it's not as easy for me as it is for you
and that's no fault of yours
and um it's my responsibility to process
that in a way that doesn't
um you know drive a wedge between us
and somehow then send a message that you
can't enjoy
your re-entry experience that's not well
it remains to be fair to you it remains
to be seen as well
uh oh but hold on i just wanted to make
one but the main point i was trying to
make that they were making at the end
was
if you come to a roadblock you can seek
out help
that's beyond just a friend you know uh
professional help to get you through
this and ain't no shame in that what
were you gonna say
i think the thing that i am uh i'm not
gonna be surprised if i experience some
some uh anxiety
i'm interested to see is a is a
big crowd like if you're go like we're
going to
a basketball game and there's there's a
herd of people like going through this
small door and then they're all crowded
together like
i can only assume that
when that kind of thing starts happening
more and more often
so not socially distanced large
gatherings people packed into places
people at concerts
yeah people are going to panic you know
i think
the the the reasons for the anxiety they
may not be rational but a lot of
a lot of them they probably come from
different places like
i can imagine that sure one of them is
just like i'm
seeing a lot of people close to me
touching things i'm watching their mouth
move if
this isn't like gosh the mouths just the
scene of mouth
touch people touching things and so if
that's something that you you struggle
with it's just the idea of the
the germs and the of it all
the humanity of it all yeah then that
could be something
and then it just may be oh social
anxiety i don't know how to say
the words that i used to say when i meet
people
but that whole surrounded by people
i'm not saying i anticipate it's going
to be a problem but
if to me i feel like if i'm gonna have
uh an anxiety issue i doubt that it's
gonna be with
you know my friends that i see on a
pretty regular basis
but it might be in a group of strangers
like that could be where something like
oh all of a sudden this
this is such a new experience
and again i mean i guess they're it
depends on where you're at in the world
it depends on where you're at
in the country these are i'm sure there
are people
listening to this podcast who are in
states where they're like
it's kind of just been the same for a
long time for us guys are like you guys
are
crazy and california's nuts we're
probably and we're affirming
their decisions along the way
well we're not trying to affirm your
decision if you didn't if you didn't
lock down or wear a mask
or whatever but uh yeah so yeah when it
comes to parties like with friends i'm
committed to like
getting back to that magic spot but then
like
then beyond that like okay because to me
it's it's not about catching anything or
exposure
or the like i don't know i don't worry
about that it is the social thing and
like
it's just like getting reacquainted with
that so it's like the party's with
strangers
it's like oh yeah it's like um i was on
the fence
about how much i enjoyed that beforehand
so well that's that's the thing that's
kind of odd to me
is uh we you know we've we've done at
least
an episode of the show about our
approach to
hollywood parties and i'm not talking
about the fouchy parties where i drink
the children's blood
i'm talking about like industry parties
where you dress up and you have
cocktails and their music is too loud
both neither of us have ever been a fan
of those kinds of parties because of the
whole
i can't have a conversation with you
right now because i can't hear you
because of the music and
uh is this for clout or like what what
is the reason i'm
walking around this party who am i
trying to talk to am i trying to tell
john mayer that i love him or am i just
trying to
meet somebody that i might work with and
both as we've established you tend to
uh be more comfortable with being like
well i'm just gonna go up to little
dicky and start a conversation
and i'm like well i'll let you go to
little dicky and start a conversation
and then once you're in i'll come and
join it
right as we hilariously told the story
one time but
interestingly it's so funny that the
whole story about little dicky involves
him telling you that his name is dave
and now the show that he makes is just
called dave
the way that it play every time i see
that show advertised i just think about
that story
but i can't bring myself to watch it for
that reason
my prediction is that everyone's gonna
have
some latent sort of anxiety in this uh
and again i i'm not i'm not minimizing
there's people who are
really struggling and this is a serious
thing and they are going to need to get
professional help
i understand that that's not my scenario
that's not my situation and i
have empathy for the people who are
going through it but i think that
everybody
is going to have there's going to be
awkwardness when you go back to that
party with the music and the talking to
each other which was already difficult
for everyone involved even though
we tend to not talk about how difficult
it is throw in the fact that like
i haven't been in an environment this
loud let alone with this many people
when that ha my hope is that
out of a of an in an effort to kind of
help us all ease back in
that the dj will be like i'm going to go
a little easy on these people
i'm telling you you know what i'm saying
because i just think that there's so
much opportunity for parties to be
transformed i mean we did a whole
chapter of this in the book of
mythicality about how we
didn't like loud parties i just feel
like there's an opportunity here
to not just go back to the [ __ ]
party where you can't hear anybody
yeah i got more thoughts on this that
relate to something
else that we've been talking about and
laying
groundwork for but you're not going to
bring it up now you're going to bring it
up later i'm just telling you so that we
won't forget to talk about it
later um another you know i talked about
the prison and prisoner being released
analogy
but it's i also think about like an
astronaut who's been in the
international space station for like a
year and then they come back to earth
and they're like even though they've
worked out and everything
and they've stayed healthy and they've
been focused on
what it is they've got to do then they
come back to this world
and all the gravity
takes its toll you know and it takes a
while to like
even figure out how to physically
walk properly i think doesn't that
happen i'm sure yeah
depends on how long you've been up there
and and relate to people
you know so i'd be interested to see
what what what they're saying about that
i take a
i take a there is an astronaut master
class but i don't think it's related to
this
an aster class yeah so i i i'm
interested in one of those
let's let's bring on a an astronaut to
talk about how to re-enter the world
socially i'm not sure that oh okay if he
makes the connection to that yeah
okay or she women can be astral that's
true
if they make the connection to that
there we go
so
if this is just kind of putting a capper
at least this is how i hope i i hope
we're rounding a corner
that like you know
there's not going to be any we don't
have to return
to any type of lockdown like i don't
even want to talk about that
i'm hoping this is a you know this is a
bookend
on an experience that if you if you go
back and listen to our conversations
as we were entering into it we were
thinking of things like
okay we're living history there's an
opportu
there are opportunities associated with
this um
let's embrace this moment for what it is
let's be as responsible
and healthy as possible but let's
also embrace the experience of it
so when we're done with it we have
lessons from it and we can move forward
i'm not ready to say that yet because
i'm re we're realizing that we're still
having the reentry is an experience in
and of itself
that i want to con i want to have that
mentality
of i'm embracing this moment by moment
um
as part of history and
giving myself grace
to to to be on that process
of reentry that it it's okay that it's
not flipping a switch
for every single person and that we're
not on the same
um pace but we
are on pretty much the same trajectory
of moving past this and the ones that we
love
you know some of them need an extra hand
or a little
more understanding more patience to get
there
uh well i think the fact that a lot of
us uh
a lot more people can relate people
like you as an example that uh wouldn't
have said that
you had any sort of social anxiety who
are like is this what i'm experiencing
now
i think a large number of people
experiencing that
is a great opportunity for more people
to relate
to those who had social anxiety
disorders before the pandemic started
yeah and to astronauts
and to astronauts so we can you know
never hurts to have a little more
empathy
uh in the world and to have those
conversations
about other people's perspectives
yeah it's my wreck i'ma give it to you
i recommend this week that
you go through your old shoes
put on a pair of shoes you haven't worn
since the beginning of pandemic you know
you got
those shoes that are in the you shove
them to the back of somewhere and you're
like i'll bring these out for something
i'm not necessarily talking about dress
shoes well it doesn't matter whatever to
walk a mile in someone else's shoes
that's someone else being your former
self
i think it's a uh i don't know it's just
like a
a practical physical active embodiment
of reconnecting with your former self
and then after walking in those shoes
all day
you realize why you haven't worn them in
a year and it has nothing to do with the
pandemic
then either give them the good will or
if they're really
horrible just throw them away
and let it go and consider it
an act of embodiment an exercise in
remembering your former self
but also deciding that you're not
obligated to still be that person
moving forward maybe there's things you
want to change
you're looking at my shoes yeah you're
like wearing like a different i haven't
seen you wear a different pair of shoes
i don't take the advice i give oh okay
walk a mile in someone else's shoes i
think it's good advice i think there's a
third
option that somebody just uh told me
about because i because i have a
tendency to go through all my old
clothes and shoes
yeah and then donate all of them which i
think that that is
priority number one is to donate but
somebody said
you know you should save some stuff
that's more notable and indicative
of the time period because your kids
will want to wear it
at some point or want to be like this is
my dad's old shirt from
20 years ago these are my dad's shoes
from 20 years ago
and i think that there's again i give
away
most of it but keep a few pieces as uh
memorabilia for your children
somebody just gave me that advice and i
don't remember who it was but i was like
that's a good idea because
i don't have like i think about the
stuff that i wore in college and i see
it in these pictures but like
it'd be cool if i could be like lock
here's the shirt i wore in college
you gonna wear in college or just do you
do you want it
just as a as a piece of history so keep
them
for that reason no give away most of
them keep some of them
the experience is is the more important
part right it's not really about what
you do with them afterwards
i just it just hit me you know all right
hashtag gear biscuits let us know what
you think what
what's your experience on reentry and i
am
i am genuinely interested if uh
if there's anybody who
what i had to say about vaccines
made you think something new and
different i i would i i
continue to be interested in being able
to uh
be a force for good and uh i want to
know if i just
pissed a bunch of people off didn't
change anybody's mind or if you're like
oh actually
i'm gonna do this now i just for my own
personal data points let me know
or just tell me why i'm why i'm wrong
i'm also very open to that
hashtag your biscuits to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left
and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best